[__] man mais viens pas là tu vas me
faire griller regarde ta tête tu P
ficass il y a aucun risque là c'est
c'estz moi ici je me fond dans le décor
monsie le policier qu'est-ce que tuas
diti vous êtes la police non circuler
parce que il y a pas de
circul brigade criminelle de Paris j'ai
toujours été très alaise sur le terrain
merde c'est pas vrai c'est la femme de
jveine mais le patron des patrons les
gars vous regardez pas la télé j'ai dit
plus aucun civile sur le site merde
alors tu me dégages monsieur c'est moi
qui signalé le Mor ce matin ah d'accord
je suis sûr que tu le meilleur flic de T
Bonlieu mais ici c'est Paris chi notre
collaboration s'arrête ici ah bonjour
commissaire j'ai toujours été pour le la
synergie des services tu es un [__] de
Lescu en fait
to monsieur cadité vient de de bobini
bobini mais qu'est-ce qui t'arrive c'est
quoi tu es malade bon ici c'est le 93 et
ben dis donc heureusement que les
vaccins sont à jour la vraie bonieeu as
ce que tu auras jamais dans le 8e
arrondissement la fraternité la
solidarité les gars quoi et du
cœur brigade criminelle tu sais ce que
ça veut dire ouais ça veut dire que tu
vas rentrer chez toi plutôt que prévu la
fraternité est du ils sont pas d'ici eu
il est pour moi bienvenue dans
l'équipe on se fait B de Cop C non on se
fait le flip qui parle et celui qui
ferme sa gueule pour moi tu es sûr qu'
sortir par là pourquoi tu mas pas dit je
t'ai fait ça cours cours c'est ça non
pou-toi pousse-toi c'est juste que tu as
l'air tellement heureux là il est pour
moi il est pour moi attendonsnous
d'autres
comiques une embrouille ça des ye
arrêtez de penser que tous les gros
bonnets sont à des affaires louches vous
allez en prendre pour votre grade
pourquoi moi qu'est-ce qui se passe ça
vous intéresse plus votre carrière je
vais aller au bout de mon
enquête on va tout faire péter chez
l'épreuve il y a un petit problème de
procédure pourquoi tu veux briser ma vie
c'est sérieux tu veux pas aller dans la
piè d' côté prendre un petit papier
faire des Pag non laa c'est ton
truc je teous
trouou ça pas du
cul